ده تعتبر حامله الطائرات الامريكيه يو اس
اس قوه عسكريه عائمه في مياه عالي البحار
وهي جزء من قوه الاسطول الثالث الامريكي
الذي يعمل في المحيط الهادئ وترسل
وارسالها في مهمات ودوريات الى مناطق
مختلفه حول العالم اعتبرت هذه الحامله
اضخم سفينه حربيه في العالم حتى العام
2017 عندما بدات تشغيل حامله الطائرات
جيرالد فورد التي حصلت على هذا اللقب
اس اس مجهزه بمفاعلين نوويين وعدد طاقمها
خمسه الاف فرد وتحمل هذه الحامله اكثر من
80 مقاتله حربيه وطائرات استطلاع ومروحيات
متعدده المهام وتكون حامله الطائرات
يو اس اس مصحوبه بعدد من السفن الحربيه
الاخرى لتامينها وحمايتها ومنها المدمرات
والسفن الحامله للصواريخ الموجهات وصلت
حامله الطائرات الامريكيه يو اس اس التي
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه على راس مجموعه سفن
هجوميه الى ساحل كوريا الجنوبيه ونفذت
مناورات مع سفن حربيه كوريه جنوبيه حسبما
ذكرت وكاله انباء يون هاب وقالت الوكاله
ان مجموعه حامله الطائرات القتاليه اجرت
تدريبات في المياه جنوب شبه الجزيره
الكوريه يوم الاثنين ومن الجانب الكوري
الجنوبي شاركت المدمرتان
يونج بالاضافه الى السفينه اللوجستيه قبل
ذلك شاركت حامله الطائرات uss
ومجموعتها في تدريبات مع السفن اليابانيه
في الفتره من 23 الى السادس والعشرين من
مارس ازهر